[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to PS 5
reveal day it feels so strange because
technically this would be the last day
of III but now it feels like everything
is properly kicking off we're gonna be
seeing tons of stuff from Sony today
about the PlayStation 5 I'm super
excited
well actually I'm Lucy James joined
today by Tamar Hussain
Hank super excited hired in Michael I am
what up I'm so sorry I really thank you
yeah it's it's really like genuinely we
were talking about this yesterday when
we're doing tech rehearsals it's kind of
like gaming Christmas um a huge look at
a brand new console we don't really know
exactly what we're getting from Sony but
today we're gonna I imagine things like
pie in the sky I would love to know
price I definitely want to get a look at
the box obviously some games guys what
is the number one thing you need to see
from today's stream time I'll go to you
first I think you I think you hit the
nail on the head with the box and the
price I really want to see that stuff
hopefully we'll get some of that but I
think a lot of people are expecting
games and I think that's the most
important thing for them to show
we'll get into specific game stuff
lately later but I think to start with
they they need to get the the base
baseline information out like maybe is
expecting too much of them to do it
right now but it would be great if they
said price showed us the box release
date and then moved on to the games
maybe maybe that's a bit wishful
thinking but my fingers crossed or
crossed for that Michael I don't I'm not
gonna bet on seeing price quite yet but
definitely gonna see what the ps5
actually looks like I would bet on that
and of course we're gonna see a bunch of
games see how they run but I think the
most important thing for me that that I
do think we're gonna see is more of the
kind of quality of life features because
this is something that Xbox has nailed
so well it's kind of communicating the
other features that the the new console
is going to offer whether it's smart
delivery backwards compatibility I think
we're gonna see Sony make a statement
about their backwards compatibility
approach I think that's really important
too for them to do its kind of round out
what the PS 5 is going to offer and
because I think that Xbox has really
claimed that space and I think PS 5
would want to at least you know get in
sort of those sort of those things right
there but we'll we'll see the box but I
don't think we're gonna see price though
but if we are hope it's not $600 said I
think on video game Chronicle today
Amazon said that that was a mistake that
listing I think a lot of people are
quite shocked when they saw it listed
for 600 pounds not even dollars yeah you
would hope that Sony would have learned
from ps3 I would love to see price today
but I genuinely think they are playing
the game with Microsoft we all remember
was at e3 2013 you know Microsoft went
first and then Sony just can just
undercut them and I wonder if both of
them are just kind of toeing that line
right off the bat but it'd be
interesting to see if they do say I
think it's the main
question on everyone's mind is like how
much is this thing gonna cost and also
an early state never we know its 2020
broadly but I would love to know what to
set my savings goal for so we've already
seen the controller so originally they
came out with that like lovely white
two-tone version and then in all of the
promo for this event there seems to be a
black version that you can get do you
think that there'll be multiple versions
like color combinations of the console
at launch it sounds like a really weird
thing to be excited about but I think
form is like InDesign is just as
important when you're buying console -
yeah oh so sorry go ahead Tampa I'm
sorry no go ahead
I I'll take this then yes because they
want to sell more consoles there's
people out there with hella money and
they want to collect all the colors of
the consoles I don't know actually but I
think that would make it more more fun
to buy a console would be like a I got
the the 2-tone one I got the the
all-black version or whatever verses
that come out with but I don't know sure
there's gonna be a bunch of like I mean
down the line is gonna be special
editions in my you know we see a bunch
of PS cores special editions and all
that but I don't know I I think I think
if you went with a like a baseline with
the two-tone color design whatever I
don't I I think that's cool to know
people want to keep it keep it simple
and simple and clean you know I'm saying
th for right so we've seen a lot we've
seen the controller already that's the
thing that they have kind of come out
and shown us um do we think there's
gonna be any kind of I don't know
peripherals like camera like VR
especially I mean I would imagine that
would come in the box but I do wonder
given the success of psvr what the next
steps for that is Tom do you think I
think I think for now whether or not
they have peripherals like the VR I
think they will have some sort of VR
element in the future but for this
specific stream I think they're
introducing kind of like peripherals and
that kind of stuff what perhaps dilute
the message
they want to kind of send and that is
going to be games first and here's the
games to get excited about if they are
indeed I think the pacing is this is
going to be entirely selling you on
getting excited to buy the thing and
then later on they'll announce surprise
and then start doing you know the
add-ons like it'll have a camera it will
have you know multi-tap is back baby so
i think they keep it laser focused for
right now I think the investment in
PlayStation VR has been significant on
their part and it's also been largely
successful on their part the games
perhaps not as hot and heavy as they
used to be but I think Sony by and large
thinks of the PlayStation VR as a
success and it feels like they want to
carry on supporting that stuff and
exploring it going forward so I reckon
we'll see VR and camera stuff later on
but perhaps not right now in in this
specific event all right let's talk
games I think yes we're excited to see
what it looks like yes we're excited for
price point but really the thing that's
gonna make or break a console are the
games so let's kick it off with first
party so personally there there were a
lot of rumors flying around we are gonna
address those go through kind of see how
likely they're gonna be Sony Santa
Monica okay God of War came out 2018
no spoils for the ending of that game
but there was definitely scope to tease
another one G trough who is the gameplay
director at Sony Santa Monica quote
tweeted the see you Thursday tweet the
PlayStation put out and said come join
us as we get into the details about what
the future has in store hashtag game dev
hashtag PlayStation do we think that is
the Royal we or do we think that you
know it's been a couple years since God
of War here's a tease on what the next
one is I think okay I think I think like
like the cost of fast and furious Sony
is a family and it's been a long road
for them to get to this point and so I
expect to an element
degree yeah I've got a long list of
these awful bunch of let's roll sellin
people now I think I think it's partly
the Royal we like you know we as the
family we as a company we as a studio
this is what we're thinking this is what
we're showing off so please join us as
like a concerted promotion effort but I
wouldn't be surprised if there is
something from Sony Santa Monica
specifically their prolific I mean they
they had one of their most successful
projects out within God of War recently
and the desire for more is there but you
know they're also a support studio for a
lot of projects they have some of the
foremost experts on playstation
technology at that studio so I imagine
they've got their fingers in a lot of
development pies helping out third party
earn first party projects across it so
it could be an element of that as well
you really lost the Fast and Furious
references there towards the end quite
disappointed Michael Sony Santa Monica
gaining I want to see the next God of
War in some capacity because Sony Santa
Monica being a first-party studio I
think that you know God Ward 2018 pushed
the ps4 to its limits so there's a sense
of they know the hardware because
they're a first-party studio so if there
was a tease for a new god of war it
would really show or I imagine it would
really show the PS 5s potential but
again and if they did it didn't wouldn't
have to be like all this is a launch
tile or something it could be like a
coming 2021 2022 that would be a huge
announcement to make
or a huge thing to show but
realistically I think I would lean
towards what Tam is saying and that Sony
Santa Monica being so close to Sony
itself is just saying like yo we all got
something to show and it's the PS 5 but
you know fingers crossed want to see
some exciting stuff that we don't expect
that hasn't leaked yet that would be
great but I mean yeah who knows I mean
personally I would I would be happy with
just a logo the bars of the music
something like that like you said
Michael it doesn't have to be coming out
this year as a launch title I will wait
from that studio but a game that
everyone pretty much assumes as a given
right now let's talk about his his ayran
horizon zero dawn - uh-huh
it's I'm just too excited horizon zero
dawn - sequel to the game god when did
that come out 2016 2017 76 hearing the
whole takes Michael what do you think do
you think now is the time yes I think
this yeah I think if the if so if
PlayStation wants to show a first party
blockbuster I think this is the one
that's on everyone's minds I think it's
the one that at least for us we would
think of as close to wanting a sequel
for because we we just got oh we're
getting a way of a first party stuff
this year with Costa Tsushima last was
part two God of War was 2018 so if if
guerrilla games came out and showed
horizon zero dawn - that would probably
be the most likely big hitter for this
reveal if they're going to if somebody's
gonna show a big hitter to come along
with this announcement and yeah I'm um I
liked horizon zero dawn quite a bit but
I think that this being the PS 5 reveal
and guerrilla games with that engine was
it the decima engine is wildly
impressive course we saw it with DES
stranding as well and just how visually
striking it can be I'm sure guerrilla
games would be the ones to be one of the
studios that can very much show off what
the PS 5 is capable of and right zeroed
on one was already an amazing game you
played on a ps4 Pro and 4k HDR boy a
game looks nice so that would be
something to really show off the
potential of a PS 5 but you know still
fingers crossed nothing confirmed no I
mean I'm gorilla like you said they're
kind of always intertwined with console
releases like um which is the one for
the ps4 launch title really games those
kills all right
yo Sheriff oh yeah yeah yeah yeah Tommy
hype to another horizon zero dawn I
really am excited to see what they can
do with that without console I think a
gorilla like that the game horizon was
had a lot to offer this part of it I
really loved as parts of it less so but
overall just a fantastic experience and
a really strong addition to the first
part he stapled that Sony has been
developing I think it's got some of the
most goodwill from this generation like
people are desperate to see more of that
and so even just a little bit of that
shown your own discount on this in this
event saying you know this is coming to
this console it would be amazing I would
suggest I would think that it probably
would be a launch title I think Sony are
not desperate Sony will have one major
like triple a franchise be their launch
file and because I think God of War
still a bit too early
I think horizon might be it that's my
prediction and I mean it's not a
particularly spicy prediction but I feel
like they need that and they might have
that and I'd be well up for that yeah
well I mean I'm trying to think what a
spicy prediction would be there aren't
really that many will come to spice
predictions and rumors at the end but in
terms of horizon I think it's a safe bet
that we'll see it today in terms of
first-party there's no one else that
really springs to mind for me like I
believe we'll probably get confirmation
of ps5 versions of Tsushima and Last of
Us if they haven't confirmed that
already and maybe some other titles will
be supported
we know cyberpunk for example is coming
to next-gen let's talk a little bit
about third party so we saw that glimpse
of God fall from gearbox at the Game
Awards last year do you think that now
we've kind of had our appetite sweated a
little bit we'll see some more today
Michael
yeah I think so this is probably if I
ever call correctly the first ps5 game
that was confirmed for the PS 5 so it
kind of it's I think it's in everyone's
minds like gearbox ain't like they're
they're a well-known publisher I think
they're publishing this rather than
developing or if they're supporting
development but yeah yeah this is
definitely something that I think we
should probably see because of the
statement they made at the Game Awards
with showing this off I'm still confused
as to what it is obviously because it's
like the first reveal isn't going to
show you everything but it would
probably make for a good like in game
demo maybe to show off what this game is
and then you can actually see a PS 5
game like made for the PS 5 in action
rather than like say oh here's how a ps4
game runs on a PS 5 so I think that's a
that's overall that would be really
important to show is something in motion
built specifically for the ps4 got the
Unreal Engine 5 demo not too long ago
but
ah I lost sound that and I'm not sure if
you can still hear me so I'm just gonna
carry on
I guess talk to myself because it seems
like no one has sound I lost one sec I
mean refrain hello nope I I don't know
if anyone can still hear me I will keep
talking though there's a bunch of games
that we know are gonna be coming to PS 5
and Xbox one Xbox series X but
personally I'm not sure if they're gonna
be here on the showcase
unless it's gonna be part of a part of
like a cold together kind of showcase of
all the different titles so for example
we know that watchdogs Legion is gonna
be there we're gonna we know that Lord
the Rings Gollum vampire masquerade
bloodlines - fortnight cyberpunk AC
Valhalla out of all of those I'm not
sure if we're actually gonna see them
today I would wonder if you go soft wood
maybe hedge their bets they showed off a
AC Valhalla on the Xbox showcase I
wonder if they're gonna show any Legion
today because it has been quite a while
every got sound back me yeah yeah time
do you thing we're gonna see watchdogs
today I think we'll honestly like it's
hard to say I think we'll see a little
bit of watchdogs
I think we're more likely to see I know
that Assassin's Creed has traditionally
had hedge his bets with one console and
this time it's need to be experts but I
feel like okay well more likely to get
more of valhalla than watchdogs if we do
get watchdogs it will be like a snippet
a small amount
as it currently stands I don't know
which one I'm more excited to see about
I think Assassin's Creed probably more
more than watchdogs like just because we
know more about it and if they did show
off watch those it's still early in the
watchdogs reveal cycle where we'll get
another small snip here and I want I'd
rather see me e amounts of valhalla
gameplay then another small amount of
you know watchdogs so there's also like
Far Cry in the mix that you know they
have one more game of supposedly being
announced and I think they they have
Ubisoft has their own Ubisoft forward
event planned which that one game that
remains unannounced is probably going to
be there in more significant form but
could be that we get a another game my
money would be on right but we'll see
but yeah there could be it could be that
out of left field
yeah all right that seems like a very
good segue to talk about rumours leaks
things that have come out over the past
few days we have about ten minutes until
we actually get to see so let's talk
about some of the things that we are
hoping for the people the rumor mill has
been going over time somehow Resident
Evil I could really go for a new
Resident Evil right about now it's been
great to have the remakes but Resident
Evil 7 was frankly incredible and if
those rumors of Resident Evil 8 are true
we could be in for something really
special Michael what do you think oh I
would love to see a new Resident Evil
we've had or I think that we've seen
Resident Evil for many many times and
hey I'm not saying no to a remake of
rosy fall I'm not I'm not either but
like I know you are Tam but yeah we had
re to remake we've had our e3 remake and
we've had Artie for many times and it's
it's I think that the the foundation of
Resident Evil 7 is due for another
iteration I think you know that
transition it's a first-person captured
the spirit of Resident Evil so well and
that was also a 2017
and I would think that you know not a
launch tile but this is something that
folks who probably want to see at this
point if it's if this is out there and
in development or ready to be shown and
I think that there's there's a lot more
meat you can get off that bone for that
first person resident evil thing and
there are a lot of ways in which that
experience could be improved so I would
I would bet on seeing a new first person
resident evil' if that is up to be shown
at this point yeah Tom you're a big rosy
fan are you hoping that we'll see some
of eight oh yeah
desperate I hope because Capcom like
there were rumors about it being cold
like the village or something like that
there was a code name for it I think
seven was absolutely phenomenal like it
is one of my favorite games of this
generation I did not expect the
transition to first person to go as well
as it did but they put a lot of thought
and has some really ingenious design and
they came and I feel like Capcom is on a
streak right now borrowing elements of
Resident Evil three remake they've
basically been knocking it out of the
park with that franchise so I've got a
lot of goodwill and confidence in them
they've earned a little benefit of the
doubt for now and I hope that we get to
see Rea I could really really go for it
a resident you all right now same and
speaking of a game that we're all kind
of playing and can kind of go for a new
one right now caught so season four of
warzone
I think updated overnight I think my
playstation is probably still
downloading it cuz it was a massive
bloody patch but everyone thinks you
know maybe they're gonna do a kind of
fortnight thing reveal something in game
there's a lot of teases as a unique
bunker that's appeared do we think that
maybe they're just waiting for people to
crack the code or they're just gonna you
know unveil it themselves today Michael
I would probably bet on this rumor
actually coming true showing off called
duty 2020 you know word on the street is
it's supposed to be a black ops cold war
type thing
but I think this would be the time to
show it I know that call duty Activision
they typically have a sort of
partnership with Sony and PlayStation to
show off Call of Duty stuff I know that
modern warfare had I think the spec ops
mode
parts of it exclusive to the ps4 for a
little while so it would make sense that
if Call of Duty was shown the new one
was shown with in conjunction with the
PS 5 I also would bet if it is shown
that it would be a cross you know cross
generation title just because of the the
player base that is on ps4 and just how
many damn people play Call of Duty man
so that would you know if I'm gonna go
full on just like predictions they would
use Call of Duty 2020 to explain their
cross generation features actually
because I think that would be the most
sensible case it's almost like like you
know how sports games go on for
generations the same way that so many
people play Call of Duty and it's gonna
be extended across generations for as
long as it can so I think that that
would be the case to show it off today
I mean we've recently gotten into
warzone in quite a big way so and I
think they have spoken that they're
gonna be supporting warzone for a very
long time so I seem that definitely
means cross generation I'm interested to
see how that transition looks some of
this next one is for you you're wearing
your blood-borne shirt we've had a lot
of rumors recently about blood-borne
coming out on PC there's been rumors
that it's coming to PS 5 what are your
hopes and dreams barring a complete
secret are we my hopes and dreams I
don't think we're gonna get a complete
sequel I don't know if I want a complete
circle knowing that Miyazaki is working
on Elden rings I would rather avoid a
Dark Souls 2 situation which I know dr.
through compared with scholar of the
first sin but I would rather avoid or
whatever blood-borne 2 is or ever if it
comes I want Miyazaki to be entirely
focused on that and we know he can't do
that right now because he's focusing on
Eldon Ring
however I would love to see a PC port of
the game we've had no in
other than horizon that you know there's
any major things coming from the piece
ps4 catalog - - PC I think this could be
a great opportunity for Sony to be like
hey we talked about you know horizon
coming to PC and we mentioned there's
gonna be other stuff and we're exploring
other things so here you go blood-borne
it's running on PC now that will be
fantastic and then if they kind of couch
that within an a announcement that hey
we've upgraded blood-borne for ps5 not I
don't think it's the kind of game that
requires a full remaster I think it's
still too beautiful I think it still
functions amazingly I think the only
thing it really needs is like tightening
up or like improvements in certain
frames per second resolution the kind of
stuff and then it's basically in my eyes
I think as a perfect game as is but if
they can improve the performance of it
for PlayStation 5 like I said no I'm not
an entire remake just we've done an
upgrade we've done a pass on it let's
roll and that would be like
I mean I'm gonna buy the console anyway
but like that would be that would have I
would be ready to line up for that but I
think there's more from from software I
would love to see there's been that
ongoing rumor about Demon Souls coming
back with Blue Point studios attached to
it I would love that there's so many
people that came into the souls
franchise and from software's games
after Demon Souls which was kind of a
niche back in the pr3 days and that
games got so much to offer especially
especially if they restore like the
servers and do the world tendancy stuff
and light and dark and that kind of
stuff in terms of online worlds it's
still one of my favorites so I hope they
keep doing that and bring that back
so in summary yes please give me a PC
version of blood-borne please upgrade it
for ps4 and I'll take a Demon Souls
remaster on top and Blue Point if you're
also working on a Metal Gear remake all
of that as well please I was gonna say
so when we were putting together you
know the note the points about what we
would talk about today what we'd love to
see God Blue Point has been teasing
something for months and months I mean
last year when we had P Dalton from the
team in
an episode of audio logs much out of the
Colossus I tried to get him and he was
like no all I can say is that it's
really cool
you'll see it when you see it so Tom
you're hoping for demon souls or metal
gear Michael what do you think for blue
point or just what do you think do you
think it's a monkey or do you think it's
a new game entirely I think it's a new
game entirely because I think they've
been hinting at the fact that they like
cuz they've done these remasters so well
for so long but I think earlier they
they've said that a we're working on
something that's not a remaster if I
recall correctly that's correct it would
be it would be yeah it would be pretty
dope for them too
this is because this is a pretty big
stage this is like as close to an e3
stages you're gonna get probably before
a live the console launch
barring any state of play that might be
like hugely hyped up so if you know they
had they hinted at it quite a while ago
so you know we're ready for it and I
would I would bank on that I would
almost say that they'll they'll say okay
we got Demon Souls or blood-borne
remaster or whatever or revamped and
then here's our new [ __ ] like so I yeah
I would I would expect I don't know what
to expect I would love to see what they
have here and this would be the time to
do it okay we have a couple more minutes
before the Sony event kicks off so let's
quickly blast through some of the some
other rumors there were dummy places put
up on Amazon two games from Bethesda
Konami 2k Rockstar Bandai Namco I think
it would be smart
I mean Geoff Keighley tweeted something
like oh you read e I would be surprised
if read dead 2 was coming but I mean
obviously that's that's actually a
reference to an old PlayStation mocking
Kempo is when I talk to ya the--they II
was read so it's very clever like
getting into feeding into that it's like
really old so I'm super young Jeff
bringing up the old-school marketing
campaigns you love to see it
but I also wouldn't yeah hundred fifty
year I would not be surprised at what
Konami do we think there's any actual
grounding for silent hill's
do you think that's why yeah I'm gonna
be positive and say yes they they're
gonna do it and I would love to see them
do it I feel like Konami needs something
it's it's like either poop or get off
the pot Konami like either either give
us a metal gear give us a Silent Hill
give us one of your key franchises or
just go and play in pachinko town
entirely all right we're gonna have to
wrap it up here don't go anywhere
after this dream further reveals we're
gonna be going through everything one by
one wow this is it guys PlayStation 5
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ever wonder like different choices how
we might ended up No
I like the hand we've been dealt
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you me together we were destined for
something great
you
did I move here I guess it was the
weather worthy dad that thing that magic
I thought we was trying to get out of
this [ __ ] sounding more and more
like a sneha it's everyday my job my
sport
we should talk about like it's 91
[Music]
we all love thanks
[Music]
this cannot be traced back to me
champagne anyone
just sort of smash things
[Music]
some hour
[Music]
[Music]
it was great to kick today off with a
look back at just some of the seminal
moments of the last 25 years and what
better way to bridge our past in our
future than with a game that's graced
every PlayStation console grand theft
auto it's been a privilege partnering
with rockstar games for many years now
and we're thrilled to open today with
the news that that partnership will
continue with Playstation 5 it's now
just over a year since we began sharing
technical details of Playstation 5 but
today's the day that we've been looking
forward to for years when we get to show
you just some of the games that
demonstrate our belief that Playstation
5 mocks the biggest generational
transition our industry has yet see the
content we've curated for today's event
showcases have ps5 has inspired
developers to create new experiences
that are transformative in how they look
sound and feel enough for me we're going
to have the games do our talk
you
a hero's just someone who doesn't give
up
your dad said that
he was right
now it's your turn go be a hero miles
okay
let's do this
[Music]
- ciao - on gravity to attract even Sir
Desmond oh hey Joe Oh shared equally
reported a super cool Cove instead we
must conquer no gran turismo ah
osaka umeda una gran turismo no - no
katachi para Antonella ginger I cannot
the campaign mode o qu sinister grin
senator Thomas as a heat Anna Simon
estate deco design
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
yeah you all right back
[Music]
it appears that the dimensions are
collapsing on one another if we cannot
get to get to right the ship I mean we
can't be that far they have found us
ratchet
how I steer this thing asked nicely
the dimensions are weakening
considerably
[Music]
well it is certainly not good
ratchet we are too late
who
[Music]
hi I'm Marcus Smith creative director at
insomniac games the entire studio is so
excited to be able to share with you a
first-ever look at Ratchet and Clank
rift apart a brand new full-length
interdimensional adventure built from
the ground up for the PlayStation 5
we're doing things we've never been able
to do before like use dimensional rifts
to be able to leap from planet to planet
nearly instantly or put raytrace
reflections on Clank all of our alien
worlds are filled with density and life
previously unseen Plus ratchets all new
Arsenal is more exciting than ever
thanks to the dual sense controllers
enhanced feedback Ratchet and Clank are
near and dear to our hearts at insomniac
and we can't wait to share more with you
in the future but for now here's another
look
[Music]
[Applause]
crackin or at least a very large octopus
I will never get used to that reality
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
making games used to be about these
constant trade-offs between the artistic
vision and technical limitations with PS
5 we're not going to be burdened like
that we're gonna be able to realize our
artistic vision a lot better it's got a
ton of horsepower which is very easy to
unlock and it's a machine it's really
easy to develop on the PS 5 will present
a paradigm shift as to what players will
come to expect from gaming will let us
tell stories make worlds create game
play that I think will truly captivate
the player and really supplies quite a
few people please take a look at this
new franchise for World War Z Leo's
coming exclusively for PlayStation 5
over and over I relive my first moments
on this alien planet
across the attack my death
crash
the attack
even death is no escape
each time I awake this planet seems
somehow different is it changing this
world is becoming part of me infecting
my mind
my memories
I sent you
I can throw my sanity slip away
but I cannot lose hope
my only choice is to keep fighting
to keep looking for answers
hope is to break the cycle
the cycle
breaks me
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone my name is Josh Korea and
this is my brother Mike
we're from amber lab a small team with a
background in film and animation and
we're very excited today to share with
you the first look at our new game it's
a story full of adventure and charm that
has themes in personal growth and
redemption
so please enjoy
[Music]
I know you are kind
he says the power that flows through
this land
yet you do not fully understand it
driven by the belief that you can help
these troubled spirits
[Music]
but you cannot hide your weakness from
me
[Music]
you have no power here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you ever feel like you're just waiting
for a sign
to do that thing you've always meant to
do
sometimes I feel like I'm just standing
on the edge of doing great things
[Music]
but something's holding me back maybe
it's just nerves
maybe it's the fear that I'll never be
as good as what I imagine what I'm still
just standing on the edge
[Music]
but if we've got nothing else to lose
- Walter
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Lauren laning and I'm here to
share with you a game that I've been
dying to make it's an emotionally
engaging story we're rescuing is
rewarding failure is devastatingly
hilarious and the memories should last
you a lifetime
take a look they believe trusted
followed and it led them here you may
have escaped there's a murderous blades
for the fate of your entire people is up
to you
[Applause]
oh boy
precision vibin a revolutionary total
Mesereau descended master imam edema
Tata Docomo Mirko me ta ta can decode or
dismiss korekara Moses Renoir Co Soviet
Oh kono sekai hudson Oh GamePro donas
supernaturally mysterious de tokyo so
kinesin Kyoto each crystal canto de
toledo - the he autonomic resign
you see things others can't
here threats others don't
[Music]
fight when others won't
it's up to you to save Tokyo
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look at me man tell me damn so give me
the give me to class
[Music]
[Music]
we're not say we're not saying
we're next day we were in everything
make way
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
it was always gonna end like this all
your hard work
all your sacrifice only sped up the
process
[Music]
and now you find yourself alone
[Music]
funny death awaits
[Music]
hackin a break here from IO attractive
in hitman free agent 47 is back for his
most intimate and professional contract
in his entire career this is also the
dramatic conclusion for the wall of
assassination trilogy I'm so proud to be
here to present a little glimpse of the
gameplay where agent 47 is on top of the
world in Dubai
enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
what's up everyone I'm syan we're sort
of New Orleans pelicans here we go
the first ever teaser for an NBA 2k 21
y'all are not ready for this
are you trying to break you down grill
you might as well give up next think you
got a chance but I don't see have got a
real tight grip when I hold that crown
I'm the first one in and the last now
whoever owns the place gotta track
your life
[Music]
you
[Music]
amazing life half body rocks a very
recently discovered species entirely
unique to this island ha
this one's lively beautiful see patterns
[Music]
and it's tasty too
we'll come to the island Oh
[Music]
my invitation is open come join me on
the island or where's where I am I was
trying to carry a lamp with my weenie
hands but I dropped it and uh now the
town's on fire Oh again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone thank you for being with us
today for this very special event but
before we get to the end of the show I
have something very near and dear to me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
Desmond is a next-gen first-person
shooter about rival assassins locked in
a time loop this is our unique vision
what talking is all about
freeform immersive gameplay a serial
player driven story smashed together
what you see some stylish action check
this out
[Music]
henceforth in perpetuity
your assistance is appreciated and
mandatory the real period of the started
million she is not making this easy
damn
[Music]
good morning black wreath another day
another death our time looks fun
[Music]
but everyone else on this island this
place is paradise a never-ending party
we're hunting me is the main attraction
and no matter how I try to escape they
always cut me down
I'm one stubborn [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
every Luke I'm learning a little more
piecing together the puzzle there's
eight targets and they all got to die
before midnight
there's just one little snag
[Music]
you thought it was going to be easy
Juliana Blake
black reefs protect and a real pain in
my ass she may kill me a million times
but eventually inevitably I will break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I don't like watching you die I like
killing me this difference
[Music]
you
long ago a young girl went with her
mother to pick berries for her father
who was hard at work
but the forest greeted them with the
dark cold silence
the bushes empty
yet determined to find the berries the
rascal broke free of mother's grasp and
vanished into the trees mother's worried
Christ I did fast as the girl ran on
over vine under branch and into the
forest II what is it with that creepy
story it's just a local tale you're
really into that stuff quit being so
paranoid are you who sent you they're
coming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Chris sorry
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
freedom our freedom
you
[Music]
the old ones perished a thousand years
ago
they're great cities
turned to graves
in their place
came new life
[Music]
and new dangers
[Music]
I must find a way to stop it
divorce
[Music]
until it destroys us all
there's nothing I wouldn't do to save
this world
I won't explore
no secret I want along
[Music]
no barrier I won't cross
[Music]
this mission is mine alone
if I falter if I fail
there won't be anyone left to stop
what's coming
[Music]
[Music]
but whatever comes
[Music]
on behalf of the entire team at gorilla
we're happy to share the first look at
horizon forbidden West we're continuing
a love story as she moves West to a far
future America to brave a beautiful but
dangerous frontier mess with mysterious
new frets get ready to explore distant
lands ravaged by massive storms and take
on new powerful machines as you return
to majestic world of horizon stay tuned
for much more we can't wait for you to
get your hands on it I think there's a
lot to look forward to for the community
they fans are gonna be really pleased as
a game designer and storyteller this is
incredibly exciting we're talking a
whole new generation of ideas and
experiences that we can create for the
player no matter where they are no
matter who they are new experiences like
we've never had before more iconic
interesting characters more atmospheric
immersive worlds for plants to explore
we want you Wow players expect the
unexpected and I for one can't wait
can't wait we can't wait to share them
with you is so exciting incredibly
exciting it's really about
I
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we hope you enjoyed the first glimpse of
our future today you've seen our most
striking console design yet and you've
seen games that can only be enjoyed with
the full range of PlayStation 5s
features and power at PlayStation we
believe in generational transitions and
we put years of work into making them
happen we want you to enjoy the unique
benefits of moving from one generation
to the next thank you for joining us
we're launching later this year and we
have tons more to share welcome to
PlayStation 5
[Music]
[Music]
but whatever comes
I will be ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay get ready welcome back
oh my god that was way more than I
anticipated that we see I mean I'm gonna
go and record and say Playstations best
III showing since 2015 the earth dreams
we finally got it look at the PS 5 uh
Michael thoughts on that go um it was a
lot it was a lot really like Sony and
PlayStation just they came out with
everything man like I mean it's easy to
get caught up in the hype but you know I
think it was so substantial I think the
games that they showed even like the
third-party stuff it's like okay this is
how it's going to play this is how it's
actually going to look here is real
gameplay
I mean it's and it's just one thing
after the other it's like you got hit
with demon souls like we'll get into all
that stuff later but you got hit with
demon souls Resident Evil 8 the next
horizon game and the PS 5 you got to see
the self death loop like yo its ya we
have a lot of time ahead of us but I
just want to say like there's a very
very strong showing and I note am in
particular there's a lot that made you
happy we get into that or like my
general impressions are like I thought
some of the things that I wanted but
like all the things that I most wanted
they were the things that I was most
hype about getting I am so like hyped
for what I saw that I know that I'm
interested in and it's a lot of the
things that you guys are also interested
in but as a press conference I think
that was like Lucy said one of the best
strongest that they've had in a long
time they needed its clay they knew they
needed they knew what they needed to do
and also whether intentionally or not it
felt like an amazing response to what
Microsoft has been doing Microsoft came
out real strong they showed off the
console and they've been talking about
it but we had we haven't had anything
from them since Sony was on the
like trailing there with little to no
information and this is the first time
they've really given us a substantial
amount of things and it's a lot and it's
games it's games that you never knew you
wanted it's games that you wanted and
this games that you now are desperate to
play and they showed off the console the
console look and we didn't get a price
but we now know what it looks like right
let's let's kick off then with the
actual look of the console itself ooh
I am super into it like I we would we
would kind of on voice chat while they
were doing that slow reveal with all the
spheres and stuff yeah what's this free
is but like man I like that it has
curves it has shape it's like this
2-tone it's got a beautiful blue accent
color it looks I don't I don't want this
to sound hyperbolic or but like it looks
so futuristic it looks gorgeous yeah it
looks like Astro baat yeah I think well
the funny thing was is that in our in
our rehearsals out saying you know if I
can reveal the PS 5 I wanted to kind of
look like the ps3 with the like the
George Foreman grill type curves so you
got a little bit of that here overall I
think it the first thing that came to
mind was an alienware pre-built PC I
think because because of the 2-tone and
kind of the blue LEDs but I am I'm super
into the design I want to see what it
looks like an all-black though because
like I think M Tam you said it like the
2-tone kind of looks a little toy ish
but man like overall that that that
design like like Lucy you said it does
have a futuristic vibe to it and yeah it
looks really sleek and I would love to
see it in my entertainment center yeah I
mean the other thing as well is I mean a
huge thing is that you can get a disc
free version like if it's weird because
it's like what is it the the Xbox ad s
ad without a distro but it's like I have
been slowly moving to all digital I have
one since I moved to America two years
ago I have one game on disk and like so
the digital edition is the way that I'm
gonna go either sure yeah yeah I mean
like I don't know if I'm ready to go all
digital I kind of like the disc option
but it's great that they have that
option now from the outset and it's not
like a mid cycle introduction is
recognizing that people change or
changing the way they play and we're now
in it's in a position where digital is
viable and and like I hope I believe
Microsoft
I hope Microsoft does something similar
in that vein and like going back to the
actual way that it looks
I'm just really really happy that both
console manufacturers platform holders
are thinking about consoles in a
different way from an aesthetic design
like mic sauce oblah style thing is
really cool really smartly evoking the
PC architecture and you know drawing
upon the kind of like the assumption and
the knowledge and the feeling that
people have that like you know PC is the
most powerful way to play games so
they're leaning on that and then you
know we have Sony with this really slick
futuristic design that is futuristic but
doesn't look awkward like it's really
really hard to strike that balance and
you can see just Google like gaming
laptops and you can see how easy it is
to get that wrong like to do a
futuristic style piece of hardware that
also you look at and you're like that
looks disgusting and it's gross like
like the accents on there the way like
it's the rounded edges like rounded
edges don't always look well they can
look like you know toys like Michael
said earlier but I feel like they've
struck the right balance between the
kind of futuristic style the accent on
the blue it like it's giving off like it
looks like you know a cool room that has
like a hue light in the background it
looks like you can see it you can see
like in in someone stream instead of
being off the off center you know it's
the kind of thing where when you
showcase it when you're playing games
you also kind of want to have it out and
looking cool and like really minimalist
style like I'm not seeing too many ports
I love the way that the kind of the
white along the edges kind of hides the
venting on the black so you can't really
see that element of it you can't really
see the ports it's gonna I think it's
gonna look really
all in an entertainment center and it
it's it's the first time where like it
looks like the concept art you would see
before anyone's actually you know a fan
has done a cool mock-up of the
PlayStation 5 and it actually looks like
one of those and yeah I'm really really
like up for it and if they do have like
a pure black one that's gonna look
amazing as well you know it will would
like the blue blue lighting on it it's
gonna yep all right should we talk about
games now
there's a lot to get through and
honestly I know that I was saying that
Red Dead would be the one that I thought
Rockstar was gonna come out with GT
fight I mean honestly like course it's
it's it should be no surprise GTA online
is such a juggernaut even now that game
came out 2013 originally that's mm-hmm I
mean when we're now you know we're
almost arrested evil for levels of as
many platforms as GTA fibers but I'm
very interested in what they were saying
with what was it's like an expanded
version of GTA 5 wonder what that means
I wonder if the long rumored and long
hoped for a single-player campaign
edition will come probably not but I
imagine it'll just be more upscaling
more things to do in online expanded and
enhanced coming 2021 for ps5 yeah I
think I think like okay I was gonna say
the the it it doesn't make it's not it's
not a surprise that this is the game
that they chose this the best-selling
one of the best-selling games of this
generation if not all time if you want
it yeah if you want a game to show off
no loading and how impressive that can
be it's gotta be this right like within
the city and then zoo zooming out and
then zooming back in between like
Franklin and and all the other
characters like that has got to be like
them one of the most impressive
showcases of how because we're used to
seeing the only thing we've seen for a
frame of reference right now is a Spider
Man stuff right like Swain but that's
like apologies if I'm like miss
characterizing the way it's actually
works but like streaming in so
that you can't really see the scenes but
like this is a different kind of
approach to it where you're like pulling
out and pulling back in like if they can
do that in an instant imagine how
impressive that's going to look and then
obviously you have GTA online attached
to it a game that is hugely successful
massively lucrative for rockstar in
terms of expanded content like Lucy I
think is probably on the mark with some
sort of single player DLC but you know
people have been talking about more
heists for ages that's one of the things
that everyone wants more online heists
and so this could be the perfect
opportunity to have that in there as
well imagine they've been just working
on this massive collection of heists all
this time while people have been moaning
about wanting heists and now they just
put it all out and they're like there's
ten new heist in this or whatever it may
be that's just like breathing new life
into one of the best games of the
generation and showing off how
impressive the PlayStation console can
be so it's gonna be online is gonna be
free for ps5 owners and if you're
playing GTA online right now you'll get
1 million dollars in GTA online cash
every month until the ps5 launches which
is crazy and I mean like if there's
anything that is gonna get you to get
back online and kind of level up and
ready for GTA 5 on PS 5 it's probably
that next announcement
Jesus this is I think this was one of
many times doing this revealed that we
all kind of lost it a little bit
spider-man Miles Morales holiday 2020 I
didn't expect it this soon yeah it's why
yeah Michael would you think of this
reveal oh man
spider-man obviously 2018 was a great
game it was probably the the spider-man
game that everyone always wanted but
Miles Morales at the front and center is
what some of our old many of us would
want as well this is it's it's man I Tam
you were talking about how maybe this is
more of an expansion based on the 2018
spider-man or if this is a separate game
we're not exactly sure at this point
there might be stories out there right
now but we haven't been able to kind of
keep up with that but putting Miles
Morales front and
is that's the right call 100% I wanted I
want to be Miles Morales I want to
experience his his experience as
spider-man and yeah this is I'm excited
for this like I've been like pretty
I respect spider-man like the whole the
whole universe and especially 2018 being
such a such a good open-world game and a
good representation of spider-man but
this like I think they can do some
really bold things with the story I hope
he's not a cop
100% cuz you know spider-man 2018 you
knows low-key cop vibes and I'm not
about that but I do want to see how they
handle Miles Morales as a character and
I mean if we think about spider-verse
the movie that was an incredible
representation and not just my Miles
Morales but the history of spider-man in
that one movie and if this game could do
something like that come close to that
homerun guaranteed yeah I think I think
that's gonna be really interesting
it kind of is both for surprise and not
a surprise that they moved on to miles
like he was in the original game
obviously and you know was part of
Peters story but given how successful
that is like it would that game was it
would feel like a safe move for them to
stick with Peter and carry on doing more
with Peter but the fact that they're
doing miles is such a small and really
cool thing I expect Peter will be in
this game taking like the mentor role
and his story could be like that the
storytelling potential is in there so
cool because the first game like this
first vitamine game is also is in a
large part about Peter coming to terms
were being portrayed by a mentor right
and he knows how that feels and he knows
how to or he's learning himself now what
it means to be a mentor and the impact
firsthand it can have or when you are
not doing that correctly so I imagine
him being in this game as as miles his
mentor and having to contend with you
know what he experienced in the previous
game to try and be a good father figure
for miles and be a good guide as
spider-man for him I think like that's
there's a lot of storytelling
tential there and it kind of dips into
some of what into this biodiversity with
PRM miles and also provides enough like
runway for them to do something unique
and of their own so that could be really
exciting yeah
and then next up we had Gran Turismo 7
um I I'm gonna put my put it out there
I'm not a big racing game person either
view Michael hey like I keep telling
everyone I used to be an amateur racer I
used to be a tuner very much into cars
and Gran Turismo
okay so Gran Turismo on ps1 the very
first game is a huge reason why I was
like seven or eight years old and I knew
all about cars because of that game and
I actually took that into practice a
realized soul shouts out to Gran Turismo
so Gran Turismo 7 though from what I'm
seeing like I love my sim racing games
and I'm watching this and you know it's
Gran Turismo it's simracing in the next
generation so I wouldn't say it's
surprising or to say it's not impressive
I think it would be the wrong sentiment
but I mean the the impressive part will
come from how they integrate a lot of
the systems and the the game modes that
we've seen in Gran Turismo because there
has only been one Gran Turismo game in
the ps4 generation it was GT sport which
focused on online racing specifically
there was no single-player stuff really
and it focused on competitive aspect of
racing for erasing but grants prose was
seven it obviously it looks incredible
like racing games and racing games are
easy showcase to show off the power of a
new console as we see with Forza games
on the Xbox side so of course GT 7 will
do that as well but I just wanna I wanna
race in the best possible fidelity so
that's why I'm excited for GT 7 and I
hope they incorporate a lot of the the
single-player stuff that we've seen in
series past while also taking the best
aspects of GT sport that we saw a couple
years back so you get the best of the
single-player you get the best of the
multiplayer
and I want lots of cars man I need my I
need my skyline I need to deck out my
skyline so you know what I'm saying yeah
gran turismo as a franchise has always
been I don't think I don't think like
it's it's it's placed within the
PlayStation Pantheon or franchises seem
so diminished not because it's changed
in any way but like PlayStation has so
many more franchises now that hit bigger
but for a lot of people Gran Turismo in
the same way that FIFA Madden knew the
speed does transcends the gaming
audience and and that they're they know
Gran Turismo as a PlayStation franchise
and it's the kind of thing where oh this
is the game I'm gonna buy this is gonna
be my racing game I'm gonna dedicate to
I know plenty of people in the same way
that you know people always say about
FIFA Madden and all these other sports
games they buy a Playstation for Gran
Turismo and they get to immediately see
how amazing it looks and see that kind
of stuff that's kind of literally
digital not trick but like it's it's
there
it's what so many banks on them for like
you make we're gonna give you hardware
you make the best looking game you can
and when they do it always looks
incredible I mean I'm not the kind of
person who plays a lot of racing games I
have been known to live my life a
quarter mile at a time now and then well
you know I I will still buy that game
for like you know the visual splendor of
it just to look at something I'd be like
yo this is this is what it looks like
now imagine what it looks like the game
is like how are they gonna look years
from now but yeah exciting yep and we
saw Ratchet and Clank rift apart what
was it saying raytrace reflections built
from the ground from the ground up for
PlayStation 5 jewel sense controllers
enhanced feedback I'm very excited I
mean I like it just looks really good
like look at all those like yeah cool
effect and it just it's it's like you
know when um Pokemon let's go Pikachu
and Eevee and you play those and it was
like this is what I thought Pokemon
looked like as a kid this is similar
form right like I didn't know kids good
yeah I think the the big thing for me
what stood out in the Ratchet and Clank
diamond demonstration the game
play was the low times this is an
example of ps5 really cutting down on
low times you because so the Ratchet and
Clank ripped apart and it looks like
that ratchet has a mechanic in which he
can teleport between rifts and go to
different worlds at and in a split
second and I thought it's really clever
that this would be the showcase for what
load times can be without explicitly
saying it because to go from one
rendered area to another it does that's
a lot of assets to load a lot of you
know we know we all know load times and
games going from one area to another
it's going to take some time even on
current generation consoles and we've
cut down on that with nvme SSDs on PC
but of course as one mark Cerny has
talked to at length is cutting down on
load times and really showcasing how
strong that SSD is and how much of a
game changer it is because because in
this case with Ratchet and Clank it's
not just load screens that are cut out
it's an actual gameplay mechanic that is
being being put into the game that shows
off that that kind of power so it's not
just cutting down a load times yeah
alright we have so many more games to go
through let's start rattling through
some of them next up project Athiya from
Square Enix so this is a new one Gary
Whitta writer of rogue one a Star Wars
story is a on this project has got a
bunch of other CID like TV and movie
writers I'm super into this this trailer
for me looked really cool like I just
want to know more about it I mean
obviously it's a rendered CG trailer but
who is this I mean is this character a
Thea what is she gonna do what is that -
it looks like something that you would
get from maybe platinum I think that's
what we were talking about when it was
first revealed Tom what do you reckon it
yeah I think it's it's weird because
like Square Enix so I'm trying to think
of this before I put my foot in my mouth
is there any sort of like traditional
Platinum's
action games that Square Enix has in
their stable and nothing immediately
comes to mind we know them for RPGs and
and the closest they get is something
like this video so it doesn't it's not
super surprising that they have they
want this kind of game near is probably
the other one year but like Project
adhere it looks really cool I love the
way it moved like the youth talked about
the dashing and like the super fast kind
of like timing based combat and movement
stuff is something that we're really
really into I'm really really into yeah
Gary we're writing it is interesting
like he's he's done a lot of amazing
work and obviously now known for his
animal crossing talk show but before
that Star Wars and recently worked with
a very he'll our friend of the show Greg
Miller on a DC thing so a lot of writing
chops behind it I'm interested to see
more of it it kind of reminded me of the
demo that epic showed off or Unreal
Engine 5 recently it looked like I was
like oh is this that game but like it's
it's got similar vibes to it and so if
you were sad that you the on row engine
tech demo wasn't being turned into a
game maybe this is it and I think this
is one of the games run like I'm excited
to see what it is I want to see more of
this another one of those for me is
stray so Michael can we please have a
cat correspondent sushi weigh in on
stray in from Annapurna cyberpunk worlds
looks like you play too dad but yeah I
mean we have a we have a slack dedicated
to cats in there so I think we can all
say team here is like very big interests
so the idea of like just an interesting
angle right on in exploration and kind
of like having an adventure game this is
something that game seems to be doing
way more these days like anthropomorphic
or like straight-up animal adventures
and I kind of love the idea of doing
this like you make more cat games and
make more dog games let me play as bird
or whatever it may be but like I you
know everyone has the everyone has that
question now and then when they see care
and you're like what are you doing when
I'm not looking at
you and this is it going on an adventure
oh I know what's in that backpack
oh no comment she's she's under NDA it's
a yes we have to do Wow next up a new
project from a house mark people who
came up with resogun for the ps4 launch
looks cool suffers from bad name return
on maternal very very revengeance vibes
from that name but the game feel looks
cool I I think in the notes that I wrote
reminded me a bit of alien meat spray
especially with the memory manipulation
stuff but when it gets to seeing some
gameplay with the gunplay very big
resogun you know bright powerful colors
lasers quickly firing at things looks
really cool I just I named man yeah I
mean it's a house mark is very much into
the like the top-down shooters that was
like just kind of their their their
Forte if you will but this is more of a
third-person over-the-shoulder type
shooter so you know it's still
channeling some of the same energy that
house mark is known for but you know
doing something a little bit different
and I mean I can't remember if was it
house mark that did resogun on the ps4
yeah so then no resogun was the ps4 was
a ps4 launch title so you know they're
coming out with the PS 5 launch title so
that's nice to see still have that
relationship with Sony yeah they've I
mean they've stuck to like arcade-style
shooters for a really long time and
they've always made amazing games so
seeing them branch out and try new
things is only a good thing for everyone
we also saw SEC boy a big adventure so
definitely the LittleBigPlanet license
is pretty much definitely in the care of
sumo digital now Media Molecule
obviously working very hard on dreams
um looks really cute I've kind of I've
kind of missed suck boy a Miss
LittleBigPlanet I just don't think
there's a series quite as wholesome will
it you know is it a day one purchase for
me maybe not but it's still very very
cute looking um big tearaway vibes there
too actually
yeah I think like having sack boy back
in the mix is it's just it's just a
feel-good moment for a lot of
PlayStation fans right like that's what
song you want to do here give as people
as much reason to pick up a Playstation
and some a big part of that reason could
be nostalgia like even if you've fallen
off gaming or you're not haven't been
buying you know up-to-date game so you
see sack for like I remember playing
sack boy I was a lot of fun and yet
another reason to kind of enjoy it and
you know be a lot of the the
LittleBigPlanet part of it perhaps
doesn't make sense anymore with dreams
existing so it makes perfect sense for
them to take this kind of mascot and
turn him into a just a straight-up like
you know platformer and it worked really
well for you know ash robot so bringing
bringing it back making it mainly or
PlayStation Mario let's do it is this
all going instead of neck-through you
think you know you take take what you
can get yeah
all right after that we had Destruction
all-stars I don't know how much to say
about that one where you guys look work
is like rock rocket LeAnn's like with
more destructive stuff yeah yeah yeah it
looks like it's got some food and we'll
see and the interesting thing part of it
is like people being out of the car
that's the other thing that's really
kind of intrigued me like what does that
mean
does that mean that they're running at
the same speed as cars or are they just
like wall running at the same time like
what happens to the car when you get out
of it is it just going to like autopilot
what's happening so I think it's a
slight mystery at this point so
hopefully we get more information about
it soon
next up is it Cana bridge of spirits by
project ember so it's Mike and Josh
Maria yeah Kenna I think I think that's
how I think so I made a game yeah it's
it's really cute it definitely has that
at least in the character design it's
very much that that Pixar kind of the
big eyes and the round faces and I think
if the main character heard her name is
Kenneth and like it's a really cute
character design and and I think you
said this during the stream Lucy is that
it's like horizon zero dawn made by
Pixar and like if that's also a little
bit of a Pikmin element because of those
little things that it seems like she
controls or that follows her that's and
then so it looks like that's gonna be a
major mechanic so you got like a little
bit of a Pikmin vibe to it and so yeah I
want to I wanna see more of that it
looks really cute I mean like just
watching this trailer again it's it
looks like it's got a lot more depth to
it then I think the I think it's just
saying oh it's got a Pixar aesthetic we
should give it definitely some more
credit I'm like that's the three okami
you know yeah anything life back into
the world it's very cute I'm very
excited for that one after Kenna we
heard goodbye volcano high from co-op K
oh I'm just going to Opie up in Montreal
very big life is strange meets night in
the woods vibes pure I like I say life
is strange because it's obviously
dealing with a lot of heavy issues it
seems but also like the woods because of
the anthropomorphic creatures like these
old world dinosaurs I guess I know who
all these things are but a cute
it's cute and I wonder okay I'm like
it's difficult to tell from this like
what kind of gameplay its gonna be is it
gonna be more like a visual novel or are
these just cutscenes I'm gonna and we're
not seeing actual gameplay yet but it
looks like it looks different and I
think that's a really big cool thing
from this reveal like we were talking at
the beginning and we were expecting
things like Cod but it's nice at Sony or
putting games like this front and center
in the big psy reveal yeah there's a lot
of variety on show an impressive amount
for you know a showcase like that we've
got we had a sports game we had
adventure games like indie games action
games first-person shooters like what
kind of focus you know what that counts
us but yeah like a good amount variety
and I think a lot of people again really
smart from Sony to hit as many
demographics and interest points as
possible and I think that game looked
cool and even if even if it's not for
you there's probably a whole bunch of
people out there that like ah that's
that seems interesting I'm gonna keep an
eye on that so yeah well played Sony
next up uh dwelled soul storm so we had
lon lining come and introduce it like
looks really cool and I used to play
quiet love odd worlds as a kid it's so
the the most important thing for me
seeing this is that it sticks to the 2d
odd world the foundation of the original
odd world games that that it is 2d and I
think you know it doesn't it doesn't
mean that the game is going to
necessarily be oversimplified because it
is mostly on a 2d plane like it's
showing off some pretty clever mechanics
and it could still be visually striking
even though it is still adhering to that
that spirit of the original games and
like odd world honestly deck is is silly
as it might lean into some of its humor
odd world is pretty heavy
I think like I don't know that for for a
new odd world game to exist in this day
and age I think they really need to nail
that they really need to go all-in on
hitting those heavy themes with odd
world and you know I I want to see that
I I would hedge my bet on it and doing
something doing something good in that
regard but overall like I'm I'm happy to
see odd world in 2020 or well 2020 was
coming out in 2021 I mean let's talk
about so for me the show was completely
stolen by Bethesda they came as soon as
I saw Shinji Mikami I kind of glad that
we went live because I made a way a
little squeal but we saw more of ghost
Wyatt Tokyo
whoof I think when we yeah I think I
think I've been down that street in
Tokyo like he was talking about how the
PS 5 allowed them to recreate Tokyo with
way more authenticity than they thought
and you know actually make you feel like
you're in Tokyo and then all this cool
magic I guess like magic is that the
paranormal stuff happens it's not the
best way to describe it but I love the
fact that it's not it's not fantasy
magic
it looks pixelated it looks like I don't
know like how to describe it like a
retro game or something yeah it's like
like magical futurism something like
that yeah yeah it looks really really
cool so like they they kind of like
detailed a bit more about what is going
on and it's just like you you 99% of the
city's population is gone
there's some weird are caught event and
like there's darkness as like submerged
the city and you have to just go around
and kind of like reclaim it but I think
it's just an excuse for them to do
really weird things around the city and
like the whole thing is like you're
seeing spirits that are kind of inspired
by Japanese like mythology and
kind of like history selected the yellow
the kid in the yellow coat is like I
think so I'm I'm a water she or
something like that it's like a young
kid in a yellow raincoat and like
influenced by super powerful emotions of
sadness and then there's like Shiro
Mookie and Kuchisake other types of
demons in there that are like around the
city that you have to battle and purge
from a first-person perspective which we
didn't expect but I'm super injured
after that we had jet the far shore
so let's holiday 2020 from the super
brothers team who are best known for
sword & Sworcery Tom you were super into
this one yes or in sorcery like I'm I
hype on this is based entirely of some
sorcery like I love that game I think
it's fantastic it's still like super
super good if you download and play on
I think it's on other consoles as well
now or at least a console one of the
Nintendo ones but I originally played it
on iPhone and it's got such a great
soundtrack as well really smart use of
like interactions and gameplay mechanics
so if that studio has been kind of under
the radar for a while now so I'm excited
to see what they've got going and this
looks way more ambitious than anything
they've done before so that team is
incredibly creative and so again like
super super intrigued into what this can
become and and what more there is to it
when they show it we still have like
over 10 games left so let's keep going
god full we did particularly would see
more of this one I love the look of the
gameplay but I think the music choice
did not do it for me maybe that's just
me nitpicking but like I said was like a
very Borderlands pick and it didn't seem
to fit the tone of the game based on the
gameplay that I was watching Michael
what do you think yeah I definitely see
what you're saying
I think for me it was more of like I no
one knew what the vibe of God fall would
be based on I think what I my
impressions before when it was first
revealed to be like okay this is sort of
like a
a God of War warframe style of game and
it's still kinda kind of like that I
just don't know what what the vibe was
going to be if it's gonna be
light-hearted if it was going to be
story heavy and I think that eventually
we found out that is supposed to be like
a looter style of melee game and I mean
you know it's it really depends on what
they're what they're going for and it's
hard to tell what they're going for just
based off of visuals and short gameplay
clips so I mean I'll reserve judgment
until we kind of get a better fuller
understanding of the system's mechanics
and kind of the world building around
God fall not surprised that I guess
gearbox would go in this direction with
some sort of more lighthearted less
heavy like you said almost Borderlands
vibe to it so you know there's still
still more to be seen but yeah I'm
definitely getting some warframe vibes
in a more lighthearted sense I'll be
interesting to see whether that's
actually in the game or just like a
mocking thing yeah another game from
Annapurna from the hyper light drifter
hide pot light drifter folks solar ash
that's I mean when we were watching the
trailer the color palette actually the
aesthetic of the game reminded me a lot
of Monument Valley but it did look very
pretty I mean I'm excited to see more of
it but at the same time it was followed
up by what we'll talk about a little
because it sunscreen it looks really
pretty yeah
hyper light drifter was one my town yeah
yeah hyper light drifter was my one of
my favorite games of 2016 I think it
really it really stuck with me it really
hit me in the way in which it said a lot
by not saying much so I think like Alex
Preston from a hard machine did an
incredible job of communicating that in
such a like a like it's also like pixel
art style so it's very hard to
communicate those things in that art
style so this definitely has that hyper
light drifter vibe but now going in from
like a top-down 2d Zelda type of thing
to a full 3d world and we just
it's almost like Monument Valley the
sense of scale is so much bigger and I
have a lot of trust in heart machine to
do to do rights by the name of hyper
light drifter obviously because they
made their mark with that game but then
next up a genuine surprise did not see
this one coming
hitman three again like another another
game that if you want to show off like
like how much the technology improves
the game like hitman is a current game
hitman 2 especially people are actively
playing that game is actively being
supported its front of the my on top of
the brain so when hitman three comes out
and you you can almost do a side-by-side
comparison and these are games where
they love a crowd in him and they love
putting crowds in hitman they love some
like physics based kind of simulations
and AI is super important to hitman and
creating these elaborate elaborate like
dioramas for you to walk through and
manipulate and call and see how the
impact like another game that is going
to be very illustrative of the leap in
technology and what it means even if
it's just a starting of that technology
obviously it man won the original reboot
not the original game and hitman two the
follow-up both fantastic game some of
the best like action and like strategy
and puzzle solving games in recent
memory I'm super excited to see whether
they where they go with it from here
it's the conclusion of the trilogy they
say was which means the story should be
wrapping up for agent 47 what does that
mean how do you wrap up a story for
agent 47 he's the face of that yeah into
four years here and I hope they they put
a shake Zanzibar in there and he'll meet
Kruger so that's what we need
I really just maintains the goofy sense
of humor yeah the one thing the one
thing I said when the reveal trailer
went up is that agent 47s got feelings
now because agent 47 five the whole
history of the franchise like
this very sterile type of clone person
who just knows how to kill targets and
assassinate folks but you know if we're
gonna go deep into some sort of
backstory on age of 47 I want to see
what what they do with that alright
let's let's roll through these next
couple so we've got Astros play room
very cute
I imagine that will be the game that
will really show off the jewel sense to
its fullest capabilities little devil
inside so this one looked a little bit
like art style kind of reminded me of
don't starve from Team Neos dream
I think this one is actually a
Kickstarter game from a few years ago um
when I was looking it up but it does
look very cool
like it looks no unique in terms of its
like the gameplay itself like it looks
like a big mishmash of things but I
really like that I'm intrigued the loop
will be yeah the papercraft art style
looks really cool and it's it's a it's a
trick to just make big eyes because
everyone loves big eyes it endears you
towards these characters so look at the
size of those eyes everyone loves it
thank god we're joined by an American on
stream NBA Michael oh okay 21 ballin so
we got Zion Williamson front center
I think he's cover athlete for anybody
NBA 2k 21 I'm a little surprised by I
guess how little they showed because all
we saw was you know Zion Williamson and
the he's in the he's just practicing by
himself alone in the practice court the
one thing I'll say is that he's very
sweating like in a way that reminds me
of the the consistent layer of shine
that the early 360 days had like social
like it's like so shiny it's at the
point where it looks like fake I'm sure
the game was gonna look great and I know
that player likeness is such an
important part of getting immersed in
NBA 2k but I mean I think they're doing
it a little bit
much with the lighting and the
reflections but you know I'm still I'm
sure they did I'm sure they did moving
on a new game from the Octodad team I
wonder what they've been working on
because often that came out of like
years ago I wasn't even a GameSpot then
I've been here almost six years so it
looks really cute it's called bug snacks
it's a world it reminded me of like a
you know the the dream that Homa Simpson
has where everything is fun better this
is it like everything let's just choose
this food it looks really cute it looks
really weird and I mean that in the best
way like in terms of a concept
everything is food but also the limbs
there's something sinister happening
here like is there something really
really sinister happening here cuz this
lad is on screen he's like come to my
village come to my island yeah and he
keeps begging and becoming them like
this is some straight-up cult like yeah
I come to you'll have a great time here
and then when you get there is like my
man's gonna eat you and become you this
is all just like a weird like I'd love
it if it became like a horror game of
slowly and you like oh he just wants to
everything how do we go his way isn't
there a Dark Souls boss that's a good
transition by the way I know I was gonna
say the transition cuz I forgot the dog
that's not awkward oh it's the one that
I had a hell of a lot of trouble with in
Doxil 3 anyway speaking of souls Tom are
you feeling ok no no I all I hurt my
hand because I slammed my my desk too
hard and I think I might have fractured
one of my hands or something but yeah
demon cells like it was one of the
things we said in the pre-show that I
would absolutely love to see and I am so
so happy that people are getting a
chance to play this game and you know I
said it in the pre-show a lot of people
their first experience of this kind of
game
might have been Dark Souls and then
they've stuck with it since then and the
unfortunate thing is like there if you
if you came into it post in Dark Souls
and Beyond like it was difficult to
experience demon souls and also play it
in the way that it originally came out
it's such a phenomenal game but like now
that it's available like just looking at
these bosses looking at these enemies
and areas it's one of the most I
remember playing demon souls for the
first time when it originally came out I
employed it from Japan and I couldn't
really understand a lot of it but this
game even still even though we've had
multiple souls games we have had souls
clones there's still something in the in
the feeling in the soul photon of a bear
phrase of this game that no other game
has has has kind of captured that the
feeling of of of being like unsettled
and afraid and unsure of what's behind
every other corner that might sound like
every other Souls game and in a lot of
ways it kind of is but there's something
the way that this game does it with
ambience and music and storytelling and
general vibe that none of the other
games capture as well like blood-borne
comes close to it
Dark Souls 1 like filing shrines
specifically comes close to it but
boletaria there's something about polity
riah that it's just quite special and
I'm so so happy that they're remaking it
and I'm so happy that as bluepoint
they're doing it BluePoint like out
knocking it out of the park of
everything they care if this turns out
to be a bad port it would be a something
for the books because they haven't done
about one of those year they put in so
much time effort and love and you can
watch like our audio logs on Shadow of
the Colossus just to see how much they
thank you yeah like and if they're put
in that level of like care and and kind
of carefulness and and kind of like
respect into bringing this game back
it's gonna be special man I'm just so
happy and I hope they talk about like
the world tendency stuff and the online
part of it that's the interesting thing
that I'm I'm interested in seeing how
they do it because demon's two-points
remakes are usually for games are quite
singleplayer focus whether that's Mel
gear or whether that's you know shy of
the Colossus there's not a lot of
internet connectivity to anything that
they've done yet
so we're not sure whether they have like
the server infrastructure but I'm hoping
you know Demon Souls was a PlayStation
exclusive I imagine it's gonna stay that
way and I'm hoping Sony and she was on
stage she was there because he he
vouched for that game originally he was
the one that got that on the ps3 and
that's why he said this is a game
special to me because souls wouldn't be
why it is right now if he didn't take a
shot on it and like you can lay the
success of that game from software and
everything that has come in a large part
to Shuhei Yoshida so I imagine he's
putting in the work to make sure that
he's brilliant they bringing it back as
and as it should be in its entirety so
I'm confident they'll have the network's
up in there as well it's demon sauce
baby let's go next up oh this one I I'm
just like I love arcane dishonored is
one of my favorite games of all time I
always have dishonored 1 and 2 and death
of the outsider ready to go on my
playstation just to dip in the
dishonored to me is what Metal Gear and
souls games are to Tom I I've never been
like I've been fortunate enough to
interview the team at arcane before and
I don't think there is a team that are
so artistically driven and have such a
focus on the what their world looks like
it how that feeds into everything else
obviously there are huge dishonored
vibes here that slide the power that
we're gonna see here looks a lot like
blink
it just looks god I'm so excited but the
premise of it it's like a bunch of
assassins caught in a time loop you have
a like a list of people to whack for
lack of a better word and you can rewind
time yeah
so many things and like the more they
talk about it the more it's like god
this is just so octane Sebastian meat on
there who he was the art director on
dishonored and believe he was actually a
fashion designer or he thinks about that
really really intensely which is why all
the characters have such this gorgeous
unique look to them very stylized and
God this trailer yeah well I'll say
about like death loop is that if you I'm
getting a lot of like if you track where
what are Cain has been doing recently
with like prey moon crash which the
concept of making prey into a rogue
light style of game that's kind of the
message that I'm getting from death loop
and also the the incorporation of
dishonored style abilities with
Wolfenstein style shooting now arcane
did touch Wolfenstein Youngblood which
came out last year so I'm getting a mix
of Dishonored
Wolfenstein Youngblood some of the
lessons maybe they learned from doing
prey moon crash all mashed into one and
like the concept is obviously intriguing
the art style is very intriguing the but
the idea of at least from what I'm
getting across is these two assassins
rivals but they're they're kind of still
in like it be antagonist to a privileged
society I want to see where that goes
and like look we got two two black
protagonist front and center here this
is this is arcane can do something very
very powerful something really really
cool with this concept with these two
characters starring in this and I I
share the same level of excitement with
Lucy in this because Dishonored like
immersive Sims that is 100% like my [ __ ]
and arcane arcane don't miss they do not
miss when it comes to their games I love
praise so much Dishonored one to deathly
outsider and the whole history of like
Harvey Smith going back to deus ex I
know this is arcane liens but that that
history that that mentality that's been
ingrained in arcane
dating back to like what Harvey Smith is
done in the past way in the past and
then now to see what this is going to be
this is definitely one of the most
exciting games of the next generation
for sure yeah and like the stuff today
like as you mentioned like I love
stealth games like AI stealth games are
the other thing that I go crazy about
and those two dishonored one to
definitely outsider I've done like a no
spot and I'll kill the runs on them and
the thing that I excites me is like they
think about stealth and the world that
they're building in a waiter so a few
others do it's sometimes it hurts to
think I remember having a conversation
with ding of Aqaba who was on who
introduced the game today and the way he
was talking about how they design
gameplay ideas and bring it all together
and and and kind of like meld it all
into one really immersive experience was
genuinely mind-blowing to me and now
that they're doing it and that was like
within the framework of something that
they were familiar with they had some
experience with with immersive Sims well
you know they had Harvey Smith and a
bunch of them have worked in this that
kind of play field before this is
something completely different it feels
like they're taking their idea and just
like twisting it into something brand
new and fresh and and innovative and I
am so so excited to play this game and
the interesting thing like we they
didn't mention it on the on the actual
event for both ghosts while Tokyo and
death loop are it seems like timed
exclusive on PS 5 and so they are
launching they're making console debuts
on PS 5 so I am surprised they didn't
talk about that but that's something
huge that's a huge feather in Sony's cap
for PlayStation files if this is the
only place that you're gonna be able to
play them holiday season that's massive
but I mean maybe they didn't do that
because every time a platform holder
does one of those world exclusives
permeate like people at the at the end
of it all was so confused about what
exactly that means and so maybe they
just wanted to have this clear-cut
presentation show off the game
like by showing at a Sony show people
are gonna have it ingrained in their
mind that it's a Sony game even if it is
gonna come to another platform later on
just like I assume this next one will
Resident Evil 8 is it is it Resident
Evil like is it in the style guide now
that it can't be called anything that
doesn't fit like the Roman numerals of
yeah that's close back village yeah that
was that was there I believe yeah I
believe that was like the working of the
title behind the scenes like the project
title and that's what leaked earlier it
was being called village so they yeah
resident evil man and really interesting
that they it didn't seem like there was
like is it as an evil
wait is this if the vibe is a bit
different from what we'd expect from as
an evil it had like a a voiceover with
someone narrating almost like a fairy
tale about like someone going to get
berries and that kind of stuff but the
fact that they're doing that instead of
just being like very obviously making it
clear that this is a Resident Evil game
it makes me excited that they're they're
not just gonna you know ride the success
of the previous game they're gonna try
and do something stylistically different
or totally different or narrative ly
different obviously the main there is a
connection to Resident Evil 7 it gets it
wasn't obvious I really liked resin evil
7 and Resident Evil so I'm gonna Yammer
on about it for a bit but like this is
another Ethan story and it's supposed to
end
Ethan story Chris referring to like the
way that Chris came in at the end and
the way that someone was like like Chris
no yeah
so like it's Chris showed up what are
they doing something really interesting
with Christmas wave the Chris yeah like
because Chris shows up at the end of the
last game he's just in yeah you know he
add a very final sequence I think yeah
he kind of like repels down off a
helicopter and he's there so like but
this looks like a very different kind of
Chris
at the time he's working for a kind of
organization that is battling these kind
of traditional zombie style outbreaks so
the fact that he's so the set up for
this game is that Ethan has moved on
from what happened in in the previous
game but then Chris shows up and
instigate something that pulls him back
into another kind of horror and
nightmare he by doing what he does it
sets off this kind of chain of events
that makes Ethan investigate what is
happening to Chris so this is kind of
like Ethan having to save Chris and it
takes them to this mysterious village
where it all pops off so it could be
really really interesting to have like
Chris in this villain role taking the
most recognizable character from the
franchise's history arguably one of the
most recognizable character the
franchise history costing him as a
villain and then having you've helped
him find Redemption that seems like a
really really fascinating way to tackle
the story and obviously being in a
village huge Resident Evil 4 vibes like
the Las Vegas around but now we've got
werewolf sand first person like yes
let's go all right next up so this next
one we were talking and when we saw the
figure in the spacesuit
we were like Luden's is this kijima time
throughout the stream you were saying
that your kijima senses were tingling
and I guess they kind of went far off
this is me Mata but like it's by Capcom
so this game actually looking I was
looking into it
the trademark for this leaked a few
weeks ago but like what is this death
drowning is this kijima yeah it's it's
it's something you know it's it's a far
way off oh there's a cat ooh so you know
oh yeah got two cat appearances you know
saying but I you know in this future I
want real cats digitized cats might not
do it for me but I'll take what I can
get and in the future when this game
comes out in 2022
we'll find out what it is because right
now is we're just going off based on
this trailer so we don't really know
what the gameplay is like we know a
little bit about like the concept I
guess and like Tamm said like this is
super des tranning vibes in many ways
because of how zany it is but yeah like
we're not gonna get many gameplay
details but man is this trailer like it
presents a lot of questions like what
the hell is this I think that's the
strongest thing you can do for a game
that's that far out and yeah I think you
know it's stealing that mystery in us is
is really important and I just you know
it's one of those things where you just
you just want to know more mmm first of
all where is deep down is is deep down
now secondly I think that I I bet that
character in that spacesuit is not human
I bet that character is some sort of
alien and has come from and the kid is
kind of like gimme last girl what's yeah
maybe the last human but like that
character in the spacesuit needs to
figure out what happened and why earth
is the way it is now and the kid is the
key to that and you have this kind of
like almost like dipping out of Earth
and then back in to try and fix things
and figure stuff out the fact that it's
coming from Capcom makes me want to try
and pigeonhole it into one of the
traditional genres that they used to
making like you know a character action
game or something like that but I don't
know man there's something about the
left-field nature of this that makes me
think of Dragon's Dogma and that was
something that they yet they're like
that was an unexpected game and it came
out of nowhere everyone was like oh this
kind of looks like a Souls game and then
when they started playing it they're
like this is like Loki you one of the
most interesting open-world action games
in a really long time and I feel like we
could get blindsided again in the same
way and have this game pragmas come out
be like this has got intense Dragon's
Dogma energy where it's completely
unexpected from Capcom and it's
surprisingly really clever and it's got
some really fascinating things happening
in it and you go up play it and we'll
see though no one's coming out but just
as we predicted in the pre-show horizon
zero dawn sequels this is horizon
forbidden West from gorillas looks
really beautiful I mean what can you say
about horizon the great thing about that
game that I really enjoy is the mesh of
like nature but also futuristic
machinery but nature and reclaiming that
back but it looks so it just looks like
it's taken to I don't want to say
another level it does but like you know
what I mean it just yeah I think I think
like the color palette is just like
intensely angry and red and please yeah
yeah I think that the main thing for me
is the sense of scale like horizon zero
dawn was a huge open world with such
beautiful environments of course and it
pushed the ps4 to its limits even in
2017 because that's what gorilla does
but the sense of scale I think is the
thing that's that's making this feel
like a next generation game and yeah
like when you see a Loy looking over
these cliffs I mean we've seen it in
games like Red Dead Redemption - but -
this
to this extent is something else because
remember in if we take their word on it
this is all in game footage so this
isn't like pre-rendered stuff or well
they're using the end game engine so if
this is the experience that we're gonna
get I think this this horizon forbidden
West trailer or reveal is communicating
a lot of the types of experiences that
we can expect from the PS 5 and just how
much bigger worlds can feel I mean we
have games with huge open worlds all the
time but it's it's different when it's
visually communicated just how big these
environments are but also yeah I think
you mentioned Lucy that like the color
palette there's the sense of dread that
is kind of that that's the first
impression that you get when you're
looking at this new horizon game and of
course like horizons you're Dom being
the first game in the series it has to
do a lot of world-building has to ease
you into those
things here it seems like you know a Loy
because it also leads in with a
monologue of a Eloy saying like I will
do anything to save this world and I'm
ready to go and it shows they're going
to all these different biomes so the
sense of dread the sense of intensity is
just like right off the bat that is what
the players are that's what they're
communicating to the players and I'm all
for that
I liked horizon zero dawn very much I'm
curious to see how they depict like
Native parallel lifestyles and tribes
because that's one thing I think they
can't improve on is the depiction of
that but yeah horizons forbidden West
this is you know in a way it's kind of
what we expected but we're still
impressed by seeing it I think is one
thing that I picked up on there is that
I remember playing horizon at the same
time as playing breath of the wild and
breath of the wild is the game that I
kept defaulting back to because of the
freedom it offered you to climb
literally anything and I know it was
some climbing in horizon but it felt
restrictive like you could see a place
and you could eventually get that you
couldn't just scale a wall but I mean
aioli was climbing something there and I
really hope that they have taken board
and increased her movement and just like
put you in this beautiful world giving
you all the tools to go around it and
cool it's like it's some kind of plague
or disease she says like I must find a
way to stop it or it'll get worse and
destroy us all like the the conceit has
been set up you know this is what you're
this is what you're doing so you're
placed into this world to do and I just
can't wait to just clamber all around it
and just explore it mmm you think and
and the kind of thing that excites me is
like how much of the like like Michael
said there like the the variety in like
the cultures and worlds that they show
him off like we had like the Asian
looking kind of like dragon like
futuristic holographic dragon thing and
that's one of the one of the things that
you know is what I think was the
strongest part of the first horizon game
zero dawn is like the the amount of a
care and attention that they put into
crafting this kind of
culture and a world for that culture to
exist into and like Michael said again
like that the scale of it seems way
bigger like we're seeing the underground
underwater stuff here now like there's
an L o is kind of hanging around
underwater she's got like breathing
apparatus and this makes me think of
like an entire underwater civilization
where she needs to you know kind of saw
some stuff out and explore and basically
Gungan City let's let's go but then like
asian asian like areas and like
different biomes and cultures to figure
out and understand and piece together
that's one of the most exciting things
about for me I think you're right in
that the they will have no doubt paid
attention to the various changes and
design innovations and steps forward in
in games like breath the world and other
games assassins that kind of stuff to
see how it all how they can improve and
I would be very surprised if that wasn't
in there so horizon zero dawn already
one of the coolest games of this
generation one of the most like
satisfying games to play I'm interested
in seeing what happens to a lawyer as a
character now she's moved beyond this
kind of she had a you know kind of
awakening in the in the last game and
then a character arc that was very much
focused on figuring out her place within
the world and now it's shifting to now
she has that confidence and knows who
she is
I'm interested in seeing how she's
characterized and she's becoming more of
a hero for the world instead of someone
lost and adrift trying to find some
steady ground to Purvi on so it gives
the gorilla a lot of new material or
like tone and themes to work with
narrative Lee so I'm excited see that
definitely well what a fantastic
showcase from Sony on the PlayStation 5
final thoughts Michael Oh impressive
showcase you know I think one thing in
comparison to what Xbox and Playstation
has done is that Xbox likes to like
drip-feed their little by little they
show more and more and more but I think
PS Bauer PlayStation and Sony they hold
their cards close for the big reveal and
that's kind of what
got here and it's it's very satisfying
man like of course this week was
supposed to be III but this definitely
felt like that scale of event with all
these different games I mean a lot of
them are gonna be multi-platform games
but some of the PlayStation exclusives
Demon Souls remastered bro that's wild
Resident Evil 8 would first reveal
horizon forbidden West like heavy
hitters up front and like we got to see
the PS 5 which is any like for me it's
an incredible looking console like I
wanna I want to have that I want to show
that off in my spaces whatever so I
really think Sony and PlayStation
knocked out of the park with this one
there's a lot to be excited about still
a lot of questions about some of the
games that they did show off but I mean
like that's that comes with the
territory and yeah of course even more
excited about PS 5 than it was before
the reveal event of course yeah I still
like everything that I saw there and I
think we saw there was impressive and
exciting I think as a first real look at
the PlayStation 5 and and the first real
showcase of what people can get excited
and should get excited about
I think Sony pulled it off pretty
fantastically it was a excellent event
Microsoft have been doing an amazing
work already and I'm excited and kind of
energized for it now this feels like
next gen is really happening now and I'm
so excited to see what they have
Microsoft and Sony I still have some
questions like across various things
like the Spider Man thing ended with you
know them saying you know be yourself
play yourself or something like that
what does that mean for the game is it
like customization I have other
questions about like price then release
day specifically Sony just for our
statement or an on statement where they
said we're gonna talk about that later
and so hopefully that doesn't take too
long I think the big question is where
those people rendered or not there was a
big theory going around
and yeah we're like everyone who was
every human representative of a video
game looked weirdly uncanny valley ish
to the point where there was a theory
that maybe they're all rendered in
playstation 5 some sort of engine and
there wasn't a missile that would be
cool like i still watched it i think you
might been delighting and they're like
depth of field or something like that
but there was a bit uncanny valley
happening there we've kind of reached
out so need to be like yeah well those
people real so we'll see if they're like
what the hell are you talking about yeah
Jim Brian's a real human yeah talking
about pride of the Northeast Jim Ryan by
the way Oh very own Jim Ryan pick up Jim
Ryan but yeah I think that was a huge a
huge success and I think everyone's
excited about it and a good saw for Sony
yeah just one more thing oh one more
thing like said questions about what how
the console is going to function we saw
a little bit of the home screen but we
didn't get much else other than that in
terms of how the console functions so a
lot of questions backwards-compatibility
how our ps3 eps two game's gonna be
integrated if that I know there's been
some rumblings about that how are some
other features that Xbox have shown off
such as like swapping between games
smart delivery how across house cross
generation gonna work well like are we
gonna be able to house ghosts of
Tsushima house last suppose part two
going to work on PS 5 are there gonna be
improvements is it just gonna play it
straight up so still a lot more
questions so it's easy to get caught up
in the hype and I love getting caught up
in the hype but still keep in mind that
there are still things to be answered
which will of course be answered closer
we get to console launch holiday 2020
definitely all right thank you everyone
for joining us keep it GameSpot for all
the rest of the huge reveals that are
coming you know we have that Ubisoft
event we have EA we have there's gonna
be more from Microsoft as cyberpunk
there were so many digital events will
be doing a pre and post-show for all of
them thank you so much for joining us
and if you are so inclined if you want
to donate to black lives matter as well
as Direct Relief we're running daily
charity streams with some of your
favorite gaming personalities so make
sure to check back and join us there
Michael Tom thank you so much we'll see
you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]